dancing with the stars pro Cheryl Burke
sizes up her toughest competition for
the brand new season I'm Rob Marciano
with easy to go ABC's long-running hit
Dancing with the Stars kicked off its
17th season this week and we caught up
with pro dancer Cheryl Burke through
this time is paired with Jack Osbourne
to get her thoughts on the new crop star
honestly we're gonna distinct of this
competition as competing against
ourselves and now everyone says that I
mean there's so many good dancers on the
season more than usual and with some
that do have dance background so I think
all we can do is worry about each other
and make sure that Jack just improves
every single week and he takes on the
challenge judging from tonight's
premiere who do you think is gonna be
your toughest competition this season
gosh well it's just like you have the
ringers already up amber you've got
Corbin you've got I even think Christina
Milian and Nicole Snooki I mean they're
just all amazing but you just like I
know this competition so well and I know
that people look for the journey and
people want to see you improve
throughout the competition so that's
what we're gonna try and do you can
catch the next all-new episode of
Dancing with the Stars monday night at
eight on ABC
easy to go and he threw the show I'm Rob
Marciano
you